[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm cabby HD here and
this is the new Google pixel 3 a don't
know yet what the a stands for but we
can basically think of this phone as the
budget version of the pixel 3 and this
is yet another phone that was leaked
into oblivion we knew pretty much
everything about it on paper before it
came out the 3 a name the design all the
specs pretty much the packaging the only
thing we didn't really know was the
price we knew it would be the budget
pixel but how low could they get the
price there was some speculation on it
but now that it was fully announced
yesterday at Google i/o we have that too
it'll start at 399
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is the 3a XL there's a larger
version of the two phones as well and on
the outside as you can tell it's almost
impossible to tell it apart from a
regular pixel three just by looking at
it it shows the design language of it's
more expensive brothers pretty clearly
but to me this is a really interesting
and potentially awesome $400 phone so
when you think of a typical champion
budget Android phone in 2018-2019 that's
the one that brings the high-end specs
all the way way down in price which is
amazing but you know you're gonna
sacrifice in three main areas and that's
the camera always and the screen and the
build quality like it's so consistent in
this world think of the polka phone f1
for example budget phone of the year
last year it turned everybody's heads
because it got the latest and greatest
snapdragon 845 and freaking 8 gigs of
ram and a four thousand milliamp hour
battery so it killed it with the specs
but again with those three main things
the screen you knows it was okay it's
fine it was a six inch LCD screen so
nothing to complain about but it's not
flagship the camera it was better than
actually most people expected for the
price but it was definitely not a
flagship camera either and then a build
quality is you know it's plastic but
this pixel 3a in that same world kind of
flips that formula it flips the script
backwards on its head where this
blatantly sacrifices in the specs this
is a Snapdragon 670 and four gigs of RAM
you know obviously mid-range but it has
a killer camera and it has a pretty
great screen I don't think I've ever
been able to say a budget Android phone
actually legit has an excellent camera
like sometimes it's great for the price
you know like the polka phone but
actually competing with flagships yeah
this would be a first so if your
priorities are in image quality
specifically this turns into an
excellent option so build quality of
course is still what they make
sacrifices on like I said it looks just
like the pixel 3 but as soon as you hold
it you know it's lightweight it's made
of this hard plastic instead of glass I
mean it's polycarbonate is what they
call it but you know plastic and then
there's some corners cut out with the
hardware
there is no wireless charging
in this pixel 3a there's also no water
resistance they didn't spend money on
the IP certification and there's also of
course still no expandable storage pixel
3 also had a pair of stereo front-facing
speakers while the 3a is giving you a
single top front facing speaker up where
the earpiece usually is and then there's
nothing in the chin it's still the same
size but you have speakers now at the
bottom of the phone but that's still
more front-facing power than I can say
about some flagships and then it's down
to a single rear facing and single
front-facing camera instead of the dual
front facing cameras of the bigger
brothers but it's not all cons though I
mean they did obviously take those
shortcuts to save their money but
there's still some things from the pixel
that have trickled down and are now top
of their class for a 400 ollar phone
first of all then I've been trying to go
bezel as' which some would have argued
would have looked cooler but that means
no knotch so some people will definitely
appreciate that in a world where the
pixel 3 excels bathtub notch still
exists it also has the same haptic motor
or the same excellent vibration motor as
the pixel 3 which from my experience has
been literally the best in any Android
phone which is great because there are a
lot of Android phones that have bad
vibration motors that make them feel
even cheaper than they are so having an
excellent one is a nice touch oh and it
has an extra port you see this this
little small circular three-and-a-half
millimeter circle up here that's for
headphones it's got a headphone jack
also on top of that this is a 1080p OLED
display a lot of budget phones in this
range are rockin IPS LCD displays OLED
screens generally have looked better
have pitch-black blacks and are more
common on higher-end phones so an OLED
display in this one like oneplus used to
when they made $400 phones it is a nice
to have and then of course the camera
the pixel 3a shares the same single
camera sensor and essentially the same
camera software as the current image
quality reigning champ the older-brother
pixel 3 which is incredible and that not
only makes this instantly the best
camera in any budget phone I've ever
used but arguably right up there as the
best camera on any phone period which is
awesome for this price so that's why I
say they liked they flipped the typical
formula for a budget Android phone sort
of backwards they used to always be it's
so predictable you know you're gonna get
some
high-end specs brought down but you know
where the sacrifices are gonna be but
this is uh this is very different like
Google is definitely trusting your
software to give you a good enough user
experience in spite of the mid-range
specs but having an incredible camera
and having an actually pretty great
screen on this phone is just a very
different set of corners to cut now I do
think it makes sense to be concerned a
bit about those specs just because it's
a pixel again and even the flagship
pixel three with this newest silicon
hasn't had the best time staying fast
over time so an even lower end set of
specs while the pixel three a might
suffer the same fate and in the three
thousand milliamp hour battery or thirty
seven hundred milliamp hour on the XL
are not massive but I still think they
should fall right in line with about
average again considering the more
expensive brothers weren't really
endurance champs either but overall I'm
glad I have this phone in my hands it
feels like it's gonna be a fun one to
play with and let me know what you guys
want to see in the full review it's been
a wild since I've reviewed a sub $500
phone thanks to phones getting so
expensive lately but let me know what
you're interested in and if you would
carry you know a phone that makes the
right trade-offs like this for 400 bucks
it's not a bad start let me know what
you think thanks for watching catch you
guys in the next one peace